GERBRAND CEDER:
So we'll do a lab
that essentially covers
modeling things with potentials.
You do such things like
calculate a vacancy formation
energy, a surface energy.
So the idea will be that
working with a simple energy
model, first of all,
you learn the mechanics
of these kind of
calculations, building
supercells with a defect,
studying convergence of them.
So that's one thing.
You'll find that the hard
part is often figuring out
exactly what calculation
to do and how
to put the numbers together
to get a physical quantity.
And then you'll
also learn something
about the things we talked
about here, what kind
of results potentials give.
For example, you
[INAUDIBLE] tell
you will find that the vacancy
formation energy is very
close to the cohesive energy,
something we discussed,
we talked about.
So those are the
things for Thursday.
And I think you'll have
about two weeks to finish
the assignment, although
the first one is really not
that intensive.
You'll probably be able to
do it considerably faster.
So what I want to
do today is just
finish up empirical
energy models
by focusing on organic
materials and oxides.
And I'll only do about
half of the lecture,
and then Professor Marzari
will give an introduction
to the next part, which
is the ab initio method.
So he'll start with some
work, some introduction
to quantum mechanics, and then
lead that for the next two
lectures into an initio methods
for energy calculations.
OK.
If you sort of
remember this diagram,
so what we did last time, we
talked about pair potentials,
discussed sort of the
formal way why they fail
when things are very covalent.
And then I spent most
of the lecture talking
about pair functionals,
things like the embedded atom
method, the blue model.
And we talked a little bit
about cluster potentials.
OK.
So I showed you the example
of a three-body potential
for silicon.
Today, I want to talk
about organic systems
and Oxides Let me start
with organic systems,
where in organic systems
potential modeling,
or call it empirical function
modeling, works extremely well.
And there's a very
good reason for that.
And I'll come to that.
You tend to distinguish
between what
are called bonded and
non-bonded interactions.
So the bonded ones are the
one along covalent bonds.
So let's say you had
two methane molecules
interacting, so CH4 and CH4.
So the bonded interactions
would, for example,
be the ones here.
That's the only ones.
Say, the carbon-hydrogen bond
would be a bonded interaction.
The non-bonded interaction
are than the other ones,
the ones that are not
between covalent bonds.
So for example, this
hydrogen-hydrogen
would interact through
a non-bonded term.
And this becomes important
when you make interactions,
say, between long chain
molecules or polymers.
If you did sort of one
polymer and another one,
you would have bonded
interactions along the chain.
And you would have
non-bonded interactions
between different chain parts,
between different chains,
or between one part of
the chain and another
if it sort of were
to fold on itself.
So keep that in mind, bonded
and non-bonded interactions.
So I wanted to do a
short exercise in class
making you think through
the relevant potential terms
you would need if you
wanted to, say, study water.
So here's water, H2O, one
oxygen, two hydrogens.
So I also want to make
you think through,
so that you realize
that it's really not
that hard to make a sort of
reasonable potential model
for an organic.
So let me make a wide slide.
So I got to erase that.
How do we erase here?
There we go.
It's the very tedious
way of erasing.
OK.
So who wants to start?
What should go in?
So we have water.
Think about it.
Let's say I was doing
water in the liquid state.
So I have a bunch
of water molecules.
So what kind of
interactions would I need?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: They all have dipole.
GERBRAND CEDER: Exactly,
they all have dipole.
It's a good one to start with.
So there's a small
amount of positive charge
on the hydrogens.
And there's some amount
of negative charge,
which is 2 times the amount of
positive charge on the protons.
So you have a dipole.
So you have a dipole on the two.
How would you model
that interaction?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GERBRAND CEDER: I'm sorry?
GERBRAND CEDER: I'm sorry.
I can't hear.
AUDIENCE: Lennard-Jones.
GERBRAND CEDER: I wouldn't
do a Lennard-Jones model
for the dipole
because the dipole is
essentially electrostatic.
So there's sort of two
ways you could do this.
You could set up directly a
dipole-dipole interaction,
where you centered the dipole
somewhere on the center of mass
of the molecule.
Or you could treat the charged
components of the dipole
explicitly.
So you could say, you know, I
have a delta plus here, delta
plus here.
I have a delta minus here.
And that would interact
electrostatically.
And you could set up a direct
electrostatic interaction.
The dipole-dipole one is
probably easier to implement,
is also somewhat shorter range.
But both would work.
If you treat the
molecule as rigid,
then the dipole approximation
and the electrostatic one,
where you take the
charge individually,
is essentially the same.
But if the molecule,
of course, can flap,
then the dipole moment is
changing on that molecule.
So that's definitely one term.
So what else would you use?
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: OH bonding?
GERBRAND CEDER: OH bonding, OK.
You guys take all the hard
ones, all the hard ones first.
Yeah, so hydrogen bonding--
so if there's an oxygen here and
there's a water sort of here,
you have hydrogen bonding.
What will you use for that?
What kind of form?
Any form is as good
as any other one.
People sometimes just use
Lennard-Jones potentials
for that, but you can
use something else.
So what else would you use?
What else should go in here?
Well, if you don't assume your
hydrogen molecule is rigid,
then you definitely need
stuff for the bonds there.
So you may need an OH bond
potential, which obviously
would have a bond stretching
part and then probably
a bending part, so OH bending.
What would you make these?
What kind of forms
would you use?
Too early in the
morning for this?
I mean, you know,
I would always say,
before you get into complicated
models, take the simplest form
and see where you get.
For bending, you
could literally take
a quadratic in the bond angle.
That allows you to do reasonable
stretch around the equilibrium
geometry.
And a water molecule
does not flop over.
It's hydrogens don't really
flop over that easily.
Stretch, you could also, again,
use just a spring constant,
so r minus r0 squared.
And then if you feel you go too
far away out of the equilibrium
bond length, you could have
more complicated potentials.
But an OH bond is quite
stiff, so it's not
going to vibrate with
an enormous amplitude.
So what else will we need?
I think we're sort of
missing one essential term.
We have very few
non-bonded terms
We only have the attractive
part of the non-bonded terms,
the dipole-dipole and
the electrostatic.
But there has to be
some amount of repulsion
between the hydrogens.
These cannot come infinitely
close together and the same
for the oxygen. So you need
some non-bonded van der Waals
interactions.
OK.
And those you could easily
give a Lennard-Jones for.
It seems like,
when you have that,
you have a somewhat reasonable
approximation for water.
OK.
If you do all this and
you parameterize it well,
what are you missing?
Yeah-- which is kind
of a vague terminology.
But you know, I think in
particular what you're missing
is charge transfer,
which can occur in water.
You can also temporarily
form H3O+, which is, I think,
what's called a hydronium
or something like that.
Hydronium?
Yeah, hydronium ion.
So the sort of more
subtle electronic transfer
effects you would be missing.
And you'd have to do
quantum mechanics for that.
And even quantum
mechanics, that wouldn't
be all that easy to get right.
OK.
You know, I plotted here
the bending term for water,
so you get some idea of how
reasonable quadratics are.
Here's the exact form,
exact essentially
as probably as determined
from quantum mechanics.
If you fit a harmonic through,
so this is your quadratic.
This is k times theta
minus theta 0 squared.
If you see, you're pretty
well within the range
of the exact potential
for at least 10,
15 degrees on each end of
the equilibrium bond angle.
And even then you're
not too far off.
This is in
kilocalories per mole.
I would say even at
this level you're
kind of less than a
kilocalorie per mole off.
Notice that a quadratic,
by its nature,
it's always your potential
is too weak on one side
and it's too stiff
on the other side.
Because if the real
potential is asymmetric,
you'll be too stiff on one
side and too weak on the other.
But with a third
order polynomial,
which is the green line here,
you're already doing very good.
So you often don't need, per
se, really complicated functions
of these bond angles.
Because usually the
more complicated
your function, the more can
go wrong when you fit as well.
OK.
One other contribution that
you often use in long molecules
is portion potentials.
And this is actually
not a three-body effect.
It's actually a
four-body effect.
If you think of
it ethane, if you
have carbons here
and hydrogens here--
it's a little hard to see.
But if you look at
it from the side,
so there'd be three
hydrogens on this end.
The hydrogens can line up.
So if you look at it
from this direction,
the carbons are on
top of each other.
So the hydrogen on one
side are 120 degrees apart.
Now, the hydrogens
from the higher carbon
can either be in the
same configuration--
that's called the
eclipsed configuration--
or they could be here.
And that's called a
staggered configuration.
And the staggered one is
somewhat lower in energy.
So to get that energy
difference right,
you need, essentially,
a potential
that describes the torsion
around the carbon-carbon bond.
If you think of
the three hydrogens
here in sort of fixed position
with respect to each other
at all under 120
degrees and the ones
here, to describe
that the energy
difference between the
different rotational states
you need a torsion potential.
And a torsion potential,
you need at least four atoms
to describe it, four sets of
coordinates to describe it.
Because the two carbons,
say, define the bond along,
which are doing the torsion.
And then these vectors, say, one
of the hydrogens on each side
describe the state
of torsion you're in.
OK.
So a torsion potential is, by
definition, a four-body effect.
These potentials
are often written
as cosines of some angle.
And the reason is that
a torsion potential
needs rotational symmetry.
If you think of the
ethane molecule,
for example, every
120 degrees you're
in the same configuration
because the phase you're
rotating has 120
degrees symmetry.
Does everybody see that?
So you need periodicity
in the angle.
So that's why a cosine
is very convenient.
And here's the ethane
rotation energy plot.
So what you see is that
it's minimal at 60 degrees.
This is the staggered
configuration.
And this is 120 and 0 and 240.
These are the eclipse
configurations.
And so these are easy
potentials to make
because all you have to look
at is what the symmetry is
of your torsional states.
So if, for some reason, we're
90 degrees, which is unusual,
you'd have a cosine of 4 omega.
If it's 180 degrees, you'd
have a cosine of 2 omega.
The last one is maybe
slightly less important,
but there's something called
out-of-plane or improper
torsion, which is essentially
also a torsion angle.
But it's not as obvious.
In the previous one, in
ethane, the four atoms
along which I
described the torsion
were sort of in sequence along a
line, along the molecular axis.
In improper torsion,
they're not.
Improper torsion
describes, essentially,
let's say you have a plane
defined by these three
atoms, a, b, and c.
How much A comes
out of that plane,
that's essentially what
improper torsion describes.
For example, that may be
important for something
like ammonia.
Let's say you have N, H, H,
H. So the ammonia molecule can
flop.
Sort of you can have the
nitrogen and three hydrogens
sort of sticking out in a
tetrahedral configuration.
And the nitrogen can sort
of go through and come out
on the other end.
And so it's in the
opposite state.
And so it's going through
an improper torsion
when it does that.
So improper torsion can
be important in things
that are, say, sp2
hybridized because then they
want to be flat.
And if one atom comes
out of the plane,
you have an improper torsion.
Or an sp3
hybridization-- where it
wants to be tetrahedral
from a central atom.
You have three bonds going
towards the tetrahedron.
And as you push that in
and you squeeze that flat,
you do an improper
torsion on it.
And there's many ways you
can measure improper torsion.
But it's essentially
defined by the angle
between the plane,
defined by these three
atoms and this and
the distance that
describes the improper torsion.
So I thought I'd show
you a real example.
I stole this from somebody's
PhD thesis at MIT,
and I forgot who.
So I can't give you the
reference, unfortunately,
but it was somebody
in our department.
OK.
Here's a potential model
that the person put together
for poly-hydroxybenzoic
acid, which I think
is a component of
a liquid crystal,
but I don't really remember.
And so essentially,
there are bonded terms,
which are really these here.
what they call valence
is the bond stretch--
sorry, the bond bending term.
So it has a form, angle minus
reference angle squared.
So it's harmonic in
the bond bending.
There's a torsion
potential along the chain.
And there's an improper
torsion potential.
And then the rest is there
are non-bonded terms.
These are the ones
between, say, you
know, this piece of the
chain kind of interacting
with that piece as they
approach each other.
And that's a van der Waals
term, which is simply model
as a Lennard-Jones here
and a Coulombic term
because there are charged
species on this chain.
So everything that goes in the
model this sort of stuff you've
seen.
And it's all fairly
straightforward.
Potentials work remarkably
well in organic systems.
And that seems to
be at odds with what
I said in the beginning, that
pair potentials in particular
are bad for covalent materials.
But you have to
remember why they
are bad because it's
the same reason why
they're so good in organics.
The reason pair potentials are
bad in metals is because you
cannot capture the energy
dependence on coordination.
OK.
Remember, if your
coordination stays the same,
if essentially your
average density around you
stays the same, you're
actually doing very well
with pair potentials in metals.
If you remember when I showed
you that in the embedded atom
method you can transfer
pieces of the energy
between the potential and
the embedding function,
if you go back to
that, you'll see
that, if the embedding
density is constant,
then all you have in the
energy is a pair energy.
So when you're at
constant density,
pair potentials work fine.
So why do potentials
work so well in organics?
Well, the reason
is that they simply
take different potentials
for different coordinations.
Different coordinations in
sort of organic chemistry
are different hybridizations.
And so rather than, say,
have a generic carbon-carbon
potential, they have a different
one for sp carbon, sp2 carbon,
sp3 carbon.
So essentially, they're
saying, you know,
we're going to take every
coordination as different.
And since there's
only a finite set,
there's essentially
only a very finite set
of chemical environments that
your atoms see in organics.
You can simply just
parameterize them all,
and you have a different
potential for all of them.
So if your carbon is,
say, in polyethylene,
so it's sp3 hybridized, you'll
take a very different potential
than if you had an
sp2 hybridized carbon.
Because in one case, you want
to impose 120 degree angles,
in other case you want to
impose 109 degree angles.
So you never, ever deal with
the change of coordination
of the bonded system.
In the non-bonded system,
you have to deal with it,
but there you don't have
covalent bonds anyway.
So that's why it works so well.
So you can describe
very well things
like bending of chains, polymer
chains, with potentials.
And the reason is it's
essentially a local effect.
You're always bending
the same bond.
And whether that's
in polyethylene
or whether that's an
sp3 carbon in something
much more complicated,
it's essentially
the same bond you're bending.
So you can parameterize
it very well,
and it's pretty much always
the same, independent of what's
far away from you.
But this also means
that there's stuff
that it will not work for.
You cannot do chemistry,
reaction chemistry,
with potentials.
Because the reason is,
in reaction chemistry,
you will change
your coordination.
So you could not study the
polymerization reaction
of ethylene to polyethylene--
of ethene to polyethylene.
Because there you are
actually changing.
Your carbon is changing
from sp2 to sp3.
And that would
literally-- you would
have to sort of, in your
simulation, midstream
change potential.
Because your potential is tied
to a particular hybridization.
You can't really do
bond breaking reactions.
And the other thing,
which is not fundamental--
that a lot of these
potentials lack polarization.
In the end, why does on
sp3 carbon and another one
don't always behave the same?
It's because there
can be charges
that polarize their
electron density,
but these are fairly
minor effects.
But that's something
you will not
get in these kind of schemes.
You know, because there's
only a sort of finite set
of chemistries in organic
chemistry or bonding
environments, making
potentials for organic system
is a cottage industry.
They tend to call them
force fields in organics,
but there really are potentials.
And so there are a whole
sets of parameterizations
that are available.
And a lot of sort of
good codes will have
many of these built in already.
For example, there's
somewhere about [INAUDIBLE],,
then there's the AMBER
force field, which will--
you know, what they mean
with a force field is
they will have potentials
for the most common bonds
that you find, in this case,
in biology, but in general
in organic chemistry.
The CHARMM [INAUDIBLE] very
well, very often used one.
CHARMM has
essentially potentials
for almost all elements,
almost all light elements.
So all these have been
parameterized for you.
There's an
interesting discussion
about all these force
fields on this website
if you care to look
at it at some point.
OK.
So another field where
potentials have worked
reasonably well as in oxides.
Actually, oxides is probably
one of the earliest material
classes in which there was very
extensive atomistic modeling
going on.
This goes way back to the
'60s before there were barely
any usable computers.
People were modeling oxides.
And of course, people
weren't even thinking
of doing quantum mechanics
computationally at the time.
So they were using
empirical potential models.
And the drive to work
on oxides was actually
from the nuclear industry.
There was one oxide in
particular they cared about.
And that was uranium
oxide because it's
an essential component
of your nuclear fuel.
And this was one of
these early realizations
that there's some stuff that was
much easier to do with modeling
than to do experimentally.
Doing experiments
on nuclear fuel rods
is really kind of
painful and expensive.
And so that's actually how
the modeling industry on oxide
was born in the '60s
is to actually model
point defects in uranium oxide.
So it's a
well-established field.
It's probably getting
superseded largely
by doing quantum mechanics
now, but it's still
sort of interesting to see
how reasonably well it works
and what it doesn't work for.
The standard, by all
means, is that you use
a repulsive Buckingham term.
So you have a potential that--
so you have the
repulsive exponential.
You have the van der Waals term.
That's your
short-range potential.
And then you do electrostatics
because, of course,
you have charged
ions when doing that.
And so the electrostatics
give you your cohesion.
That's the one that wants
to bring the ions together.
And the Buckingham term
gives you your repulsion.
To sum the long range
electrostatic part,
people can sum in real space.
If you sum this in
real space, it's
only conditionally convergent.
And people use what's
called the Ewald method.
It's something you'll
see when you use codes.
There actually are
faster techniques now,
but this is still
definitely a standard.
We're not going to
go into details,
but essentially the
Ewald way is a way
of partitioning your
energy sum in real space
and in reciprocal space,
so that both converge.
You can actually show
that, in either space,
it doesn't converge very well.
In real space, 1 over
r doesn't converge.
In reciprocal space, it
really doesn't converge
when you Fourier transform it.
But you can partition
it, so that it
converges in both space.
And you basically
have to sum it up.
And an essential piece that
was added in the late '60,
early '70s was polarization.
An important thing in
oxides is that you have
strong electrostatic fields.
So when you put an electron
density in a field,
it can polarize.
And this is particularly
important for the oxygen ion.
If you put the oxygen ion in a
non-symmetric position, so one
where the field doesn't
vanish, an oxygen ion
is highly negatively charged.
It means it has a
lot of electrons.
So the electron density
cloud will polarize.
And the oxygen will
actually carry a dipole.
And that was actually modeled
in a sort of very ingenious way,
I thought.
The way polarization
is included is
by what's called a
shell and spring model.
Essentially, you treat
the polarizable ion
by two entities.
It has a nucleus
with a charge on it,
and it has a shell
with a charge on it.
And the two charges sum
to the charge of the ion.
So if this were oxygen,
this would be 2 minus then.
But what you do is the two
can move independently,
but they are
connected by a spring.
So they can't completely wander
off, so they are connected.
But what happens now
if you put-- say,
if you put a field
on this, the positive
and the negative charge will
move in opposite direction.
So you may go to a state
where the center, qn,
the center of the
positive charge is here.
And that's the shell.
And so, now, this would be the
center of the positive charge.
And the center of the negative
charge would be shifted.
And you would have a dipole.
So does everybody
see how this works?
So the polarizability of
the ion is essentially
determined by the
charge difference
between the shell and the core
and the spring between them.
If the spring is
infinitely stiff,
then you cannot
polarize the ion.
If the spring is soft, then you
can polarize the ion very well.
And that's actually how the
spring constant is fitted.
It's fitted to the
polarizability, often,
of the free ion.
And I think this is
actually the polarization.
Typically, what interacts
with the other ions
through the short range
term is the shell model.
Usually, when you model
oxides with potentials,
you tend to put a shell and
spring only on the anions
because it's obviously the
anion that's most polarizable.
It has the biggest
electron density cloud.
It has the electrons.
And cations are much
less polarizable
because they're cations.
They have lost most of
their valence electrons.
Especially something
like-- let's say
you do MgO, magnesium oxide.
Magnesium is 2+, so
magnesium is an outlier.
So it's a bare core.
If you strip off two
electrons, there's
nothing left to polarize
unless you think you're
going to polarize the core.
So you would there
just put a shell
on a spring on the oxygen.
This becomes very important
when you work in low
symmetry environments.
Because whether your
ion polarizes or not
depends on whether the
symmetry allows it to polarize.
If you are sitting in a
center of point symmetry,
let's say you're sitting in an
inversion center of a crystal,
I don't care how
polarizable you are.
The symmetry doesn't
allow you to polarize.
But so it's when you do low
symmetry calculation, defects,
surfaces, that polarizability
becomes quite important.
So I wanted to show
you a real example.
This is something we kind
of quickly calculated
ourselves a few years ago.
That's why it looks
like a crummy graph.
Because this is the phonon
density of state for magnesium
oxide with and
without polarization.
So what this is is
really this axis
is the frequency of the phonons.
And this is the
density of states,
how many phonons there are
with that frequency of energy.
And essentially,
what you see is that,
when you have no
polarization, you
have a high frequency
tail of phonons.
And remember, phonons--
even though MgO
is a highly symmetric
crystal, the energy of phonons
is determined by
low symmetry things.
Because, you know, think of
a displacement of a phonon.
You're now breaking the
translational symmetry.
So you're not into
high symmetry 0 Kelvin
crystalline environment
anymore, so polarization
becomes relevant.
When you turn on
polarization of the anions,
you essentially dampen away
those high frequencies.
OK.
Let me actually, just
before I go here, come back
to the issue of polarization is
important to take into account
when you fit.
There are people who
will show you potentials
fit to the equation of state.
So does everybody
know what I mean?
The equation of state, I
mean literally the energy
of the system as a
function of state lattice
parameter or volume.
So let's say I took MgO,
magnesium oxides or rock salt.
I could really, let's say,
have initial calculations
of different lattice parameters.
And that would give
me a curve, energy
versus lattice parameters.
I could fit my
potential to that.
If I do that, I have never
included any polarization
effects.
Because at every
lattice parameter,
that is still a
high symmetry state.
At none of these
lattice parameters
is any of the ions
ever polarized,
ever have a dipole moment on it.
And so what you see
then, when you go and do
defect calculations
with that potential,
you will almost always
overestimate their energy.
And the reason is
you've taken away
a degree of freedom
of the system.
If you actually then
calculate a defect,
the system wants to polarize,
but you haven't given it
the option because you haven't
included it in your model.
So I would say be
aware of people who
show you equations of state.
You know, everybody can fit an
equation of state, everybody.
You know, any potential that has
more than one fitting parameter
can fit an equation of state.
It's the low symmetry details,
surface energies, defects,
that are hard to reproduce.
These days, just
like in organics,
there are very good sources
of potentials for oxides.
You don't really have
to go and fit your own.
This is one paper that sort
of collected a bunch of them,
which is a paper by Bush.
They're actually on the web now.
You can literally download
them in the format
right away that's relevant
for a particular code,
the set of standardized codes.
The one we'll use in
the lab is called GULP,
which is free for academics.
But even other codes you can
pretty much get the form often
right off the web.
OK.
Oh, this is actually one of
the tables in that paper.
All I'm showing you this is that
you can see that they actually
have the parameters.
So this is the
parameter in front
of the exponential between
the cation and the anion.
This is the one in
the exponential.
Remember, it's a
exponential minus r overall.
This would be the
polarization, the core,
and the shell polarization.
In this case, on
some of the cations,
they put it on as well.
On the alkalis, they
didn't fit a polarization,
since they're really not
very polarizable if you
see lithium, sodium, potassium.
But on some of the
heavier cations,
they did fit polarization terms.
But the main
important polarization
is the one on the
oxygen. So you have
a core charge and a shell
charge and a spring constant.
This is actually the
anion spring constant.
The nice thing about
these potentials
is that they were
fit all together.
They actually fitted all these
potentials, the cation, anion,
and the anion-ion terms
all in one massive fitting.
And what that means
is that they have
a consistent
anion-anion potential
across multiple oxides.
The problem with fitting
potentials in oxide
has always been the
oxygen-oxygen one.
Because in an oxide,
the oxygens are big.
They're about 1.4 angstrom.
A cation is small.
Like, magnesium is,
say, 0.7 angstrom.
So really an oxide is big
oxygens touching each other
and the cations sitting in
the spaces between them.
So the potential
between the oxygens
is always the one
that kind of sets
a lot of your dynamical effects,
a lot of your lattice parameter
effects.
So it's the one that's
hardest to deal with.
It's also the problem.
If there's a reason that
this sometimes fails,
it's often because of
the anion potential.
Even though we think
of oxygen as a 2- ion,
it turns out it's actually
a very fluffy ion.
That last p electron you
put on it to make it 2-
is actually not stably
bound in a vacuum.
It's bound largely by
the electrostatic field
in the crystal.
Remember, from the cations
comes a positive field.
So the electron really wants
to be there on the oxygen.
And that's what binds
the last p electron.
So the problem
with the oxygen is
that it relaxes
its wave functions
depending on environment.
So it's not a hard ion at all.
And that's often
referred to as breeding.
The oxygen breeds.
So what that really means--
that the oxygen doesn't
have the same size in
different environments.
And this is where it gets
problematic for potentials
because you model your
potential with, remember,
this Buckingham potential, which
has a well-defined minimum.
It sort of treats the oxygen
as the same every time,
but this breeding basically
messes that up somewhat,
that your oxygen has
somewhat different sides
in different environments.
If you're doing monoxides,
you pick that up
in that difference in the
cation anion potential.
If you're just comparing, say,
MgO and CaO, magnesium oxide
and calcium oxide,
you can pick up
the inconsistency between
the oxygen-oxygen potential
in the two by modifying
the metal oxygen
potential somewhat.
But it's going to do complicated
oxides with a lot of metals.
And at the same time you quite
can't play that game anymore.
This is the charge density of
the oxygen in calcium oxide.
And on the same scale,
this is the charge density
in magnesium oxide.
If you actually see,
it's not quite the same.
It's actually not nearly as
spherical in calcium oxide
as in magnesium oxide.
And calcium is bigger.
And these are in exactly
the same structure.
The last one is really
the more problematic one,
is that most oxides are
actually-- more and more,
we find out that they
are less hard in valence
than we thought they were.
We always think of oxides as
there's 2- on the oxygens.
And then I figured out
what my cation charge is.
And for lithium, it's 1+.
For magnesium, it's 2+.
What we find more and more
is that the ions really don't
have full charge in oxides.
So what I showed you here, this
is mixtures of zirconium oxide
and calcium oxide.
And what is shown, the negative
numbers that are shown,
are the charges on the
oxygen. And what you see
is that they're kind
of all over the map.
They depend, essentially, on
what cations are around them.
Zirconium is 4+.
Calcium is 2+.
So if you actually have a
lot of zirconium around,
you tend to make the
oxygen more negative than
if you have calcium around you.
And so what this
essentially means
is that, when you do
empirical potential modeling
and you use full
charges, in some sense,
your energetics is too harsh.
You tend to
overestimate energies
because you have too large an
electrostatic contribution.
In reality, when you treat
the full electron density
in quantum mechanics,
the electron density
will relax away a little
from these full charges
and, thereby, sort of moderate
the electrostatic effect.
So this is probably
the hardest problem
in modeling oxides of
empirical potentials.
This becomes
extremely problematic
when you do transition metal
oxides because transition metal
have variable valence.
Magnesium, at least, we
always think of as 2+.
But what if you're
doing iron oxides?
Iron can be 2+, 3+, or 4+.
And at some point, you will
do conformation changes
in your material, and
your valence will change.
And you can't deal with
that in a pair potential
because it's the
same as in organics.
A 2+ and a 3+ iron have a
different potential with oxygen
because they have a
different repulsion.
And so there are people who
have tried to make models
with variable charge where you
have literally the short range
repulsion, the
electrostatic term,
and then a kind of
ionization term.
So you would actually minimize
not just over atomic positions,
but also over
charges on the ions.
So there would be
some function that
tells you how hard it is to
pull an electron off and put it
on another.
It's just that after
a while you run
into so many fitting problems.
The more parameters
you have in your model,
the more things you have to
fit that you have to wonder
whether it's worth doing that.
And these models have not
sort of caught on in general.
If you're interested, I can
give you some references,
but they're not quite
in widespread use.
So I kind of talked
about this here,
the limitations
of pair potentials
in oxides, the oxygen
change, the charge effect,
and so many body effects.
So let me sort of
summarize this,
and then I'll hand over
Professor Marzari what
I think we've seen.
So in metals, you have
the issue of coordination.
If you should
remember one thing,
it's bond strength
depends on coordination.
And you should remember
how that showed up
in things like vacancy
formation energies and things
like surface contraction.
When you make a surface, the
layers tend to contract in.
So if you have less
bonds, they're stronger.
And that's the problem
for pair potentials.
And methods like
embedded atom method
do a great job of
fixing that problem.
They're still missing
a lot of things.
They don't have, in the end,
subtle electronic hybridization
effects.
So you still won't get
everything out of them,
but they fixed
that main problem.
In organic molecules,
the reason you're saved
is because essentially you have
a limited set of environments.
And you really parameterize
for each of them.
And people have essentially
done that for you.
The work is done.
In oxides, I would say
they're sort of in between.
You do reasonably
well for things
that are sort of gross
topological changes.
But because of the variable
charge effect, the oxygen
breeding, and sometimes
charge transfer,
you will miss that
subtle energetic effect.
The other thing is that,
in transition metals,
you often have magnetic moments.
In transition metals, you have
a lot of unpaired electrons
because the orbitals
are very localized.
So you will tend to populate
them following Hund's rules.
So you will tend to build up
magnetic moments on the ions.
And so you will have
magnetic interactions.
And these are almost never
dealt with in pair potentials.
So I'm going to hand off here to
Professor Marzari, who's going
to teach you quantum mechanics.
NICOLA MARZARI: Excellent.
So welcome to the second
part of the lecture.
What we are going to see
in the next few classes
are actually electronic
structure methods
for modeling materials.
And what I've
decided to do today
is really just a brief
introduction and a refresher
of quantum mechanics
or just an introduction
if you haven't seen before.
And this is mostly
because, at the end,
electronic structure
methods involves
the solution of a
Schrodinger equation
or a relative of the
Schrodinger equation.
And so I wanted to
remind you about that.
This is sort of what we can do
more or less easily nowadays.
This is a system with
a few hundred atoms.
It's actually myoglobin
with a carbon monoxide
molecules attached to it.
And it's the kind
of calculation that
would take a day or so on
a smaller research cluster.
It's also a calculation that
basically predicts that we all
would be dead in a
nanosecond or so,
just because the error in the
binding energy of that molecule
that you get with the standard
quantum mechanical method
is actually not enough to sort
of compare with experiments.
So let's see a few cases
in sort of which we
think quantum mechanical
simulations are very relevant.
The first case is one of
structure and bonding.
Basically, a solid or a
molecule stays together
because there is an
electronic glue that
compensate the repulsion
between the nuclei.
And the structure and stability
of different structures
is determined by
the compensation
of repulsive effects.
So all nuclear repel each other.
All electrons repel each
other, but nuclei and electrons
attract each other.
And say, here we are seeing
two different structures.
On the left is the
high temperature
cubic phase of lead titanite.
And on the right, we
have the low temperature
ferroelectric phase
of lead titanite.
And you see it has
very subtle differences
and very subtle differences
in the charge density.
At the end, a solid
is really made
by spherical atoms
that sort of interfere
very lightly, destructively,
or constructively.
And here you can see
sort of affirmation
of some kind of stronger bond
between the white oxygen,
in this case, and
the green lead atoms.
And we are at the
stage in which sort
of state of the art electronic
structure approaches
are actually able to calculate
accurately these energy
differences.
And so they can give you
the zero temperature phase
stability.
And as you learn in
the rest of the class,
once you have a good
energetic model,
you can also calculate
the thermodynamics.
Basically, thermodynamics
is the statistical mechanics
of the thermal excitation
for such a system.
Another case in which
electronic structure methods
are obviously important
is when you are actually
interested in electronic
structure properties.
So if you want to
calculate or predict
electronic properties,
optical properties,
and, to a large extent,
magnetic properties,
you really can't
use a potential.
A potential, if anything,
gives you a structure,
but will never give you
the electronic excitation.
And this is actually a beautiful
case from recent research.
This is from Professor Bawendi
in the chemistry department.
And what you are
seeing here is actually
a suspension of cadmium
selenides nanoparticles.
And to a large extent,
the optical excitation
can actually be modeled
just by the excitation
of an electron confined
in a spherical potential.
Also, one can do sort
of better than that.
But what's happening
here is that,
depending on the size, the
spacing between the excited
level changes.
And basically,
this system absorbs
light in different ways.
And so they can actually make
for great chemical sensors.
And this is, again,
electronic properties
is what we predict
with quantum mechanics.
And finally, we can follow
chemical bonding, chemical
breaking and chemical
forming reactions.
So say you want to study
a chemical reaction.
And this is a sort of classic
case for organic chemistry.
This is a cycloaddition
reaction or what
is called a Diels-Alder
reaction in which, basically,
an ethylene molecule
break apart,
and we form an aromatic bond.
Well, this is something
that you could
do with quantum mechanics.
This is a picture that comes
from Bill Goddard's site in Cal
Tech.
And you see we are
actually following
the highest occupied molecular
orbital as the reaction
proceeds.
And this is really the reason
why a potential wouldn't
be able to describe
this to a large extent
because what is
taking place is really
a reorganization of
the electronic state.
You see, ultimately, it's really
constructive and destructive
interference of
electrons as standing
waves in this potential that
determine the stability.
And again, this is
sort of done with sort
of current state of the art
electronics structure methods.
So this is what we are
going to learn, basically.
And a picture that I always
want you to have in mind
is what I call the
standard model of matter.
That is everything you
look at, a beta solid,
a gas, or a molecule,
ultimately can
be described as sort of
the current condition,
so at the sort of
average energy that
is typical of room
temperature or sort of roughly
orders of magnitude
above and below it.
First of all, by
ionic nuclei, that
is really where all the mass
of your system is concentrated.
Remember, a sort of nucleus as
actually a typical size of 10
to the minus 14, 10 to
the minus 15 meters.
But it's really where
all the mass lies.
And the amazing thing--
I always find this amazing--
is that to a large extent,
even for a nucleus,
Newton's equation of
motion still apply.
I mean, in reality,
there are sort
of a number of subtle
quantum effects.
We'll mention this sort of
in the course of this class.
But for all practical
purposes, you
should start thinking
as this nuclei
as behaving as
classical particles
and moving around following the
Newton's equation of motion.
So they have a mass,
and they feel a force.
And the force that
they feel is basically
a repulsive force from
all the other nuclei
and the attractive force
from this electronic glue.
These nuclei are actually
surrounded by electrons.
When you study the
periodic table,
you have studied all
the orbital shells.
And really what happens is that
all the lowest core electrons
are so tightly bound
that they really do not
sort of change in the process of
the forming of a chemical bond
or the breaking of
a chemical bond.
So say, if you are thinking at
any sort of second row element,
carbon, nitrogen,
oxygen, well, we
know that there are 1s
electrons in there, sort
of the one that we
have first filled.
Those 1s electrons
are core electrons.
And they really do not change
in the evolution of this system,
unless we are really at energy
so high that we can start sort
of kicking those
around, but that doesn't
happen for practical purposes.
So again, in your
standard model of matter,
you need to think the nucleus
surrounded by very tightly
bound shell of electrons.
And it's really only
the outer electrons,
what we call the
valence electrons, that
are those are so lightly bound
to the nucleus that can start
creating constructive and
destructive interference when
they fill another nucleus.
And so they create
chemical bonds.
See, if you just look
at the, say, charge
density in something
like platinum,
this is sort of a
platinum surface
to which a methane molecule
is attached to sort
of the beginning of catalysis.
You see, at the
end, what we have
we have spherical atoms with
very, very tiny bonding.
And again, it's not very
different from the picture
that we have seen before of the
oxygen atom in calcium oxide.
Obviously, all the relevant
energy is in this bonding.
The difference between platinum
in the metal state or, say,
a platinum atom
solvated in water,
is the difference in
this chemical bonding.
So studying what happens
here is very important.
But to a large extent, this
sort of general picture
of the charge density of
the atom being spherical
is conserved.
It's even in a
covalently bonded system.
This is a metallic
bonded system, platinum.
Up here, we have a covalent
bonded system that is methane.
And again, to a
large extent, you
see the spheres
that are the atoms.
But all what we care
in understanding
the stability of
different structure
is actually what those
last valence electrons do.
And obviously, those are
the lastly bound one.
When you start sort of creating
an atom, you have a nucleus.
And you start putting electrons.
You fill up sort
of all the levels.
The first one are incredibly
tightly bound to the nucleus.
And then the more you
add, the more these
electrons screen the nucleus.
And so the next
electrons are going
to see less and less
attractive charge to the point
that the last electron
sees really very
little attractive charge.
And so it's a valence
electron ready to bind.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
NICOLA MARZARI:
Very, very good--
this is the difference
between if you
want the classical
behavior of particle
and the quantum mechanical
behavior of particle.
Ultimately, I like to think
of it as the indetermination
principle.
That is, if the electron
were to fall on the nucleus,
we would be in a
situation in which
both its position
and its momentum
are known with
infinite precision.
And that is something
that doesn't
happen in quantum mechanics.
And we'll see it
in a different way.
Ultimately, electrons
behave as wave.
And so the ground
state of that wave
is something in
which the electron
can't live on the nucleus.
If you want another
sort of analogy,
could be one of an organ pipe.
If you have an organ pipe,
there is a fundamental harmonic
that you can play
and high harmonics.
But there is nothing
lower in energy or sort
of deeper in bass than
the fundamental harmonic.
So because, basically,
electrons behave
as quantum mechanical particles,
that is behave as wave,
their lowest energy
meaningful state
is one in which they do not
collapse to the nucleus,
but they sort of
create-- and we'll
see this in a moment-- sort
of an appropriate interference
a stable stationary
state around the nucleus.
And sort of, if you want,
this is the difference
between quantum mechanics
and classical mechanics.
If an electron was a
classical particle,
it would collapse
on the nucleus.
Because it's not, it doesn't.
And you know, quantum mechanics
has been largely understanding
what are these rules that
quantum object follows
that are just different.
And you know, sort of you'll
see some of these rules.
And there are sort of different
ways in explaining this.
I like to think that basically
the indetermination principle.
At the end, a quantum
particle has a certain amount
of indetermination that
can actually be quantified.
If that quantum particle were
to collapse on the nucleus,
the indetermination of the
two conjugate variables,
the momentum and the
position, would actually be 0.
And that can't happen.
You know, as much as you start,
say, in classical mechanics,
that a particle follows
Newton's equation of motion
and not something different,
in quantum mechanics,
you learn a set of rules that
these quantum particles follow
and that have been verified.
And one of these
rules basically says
that the lowest energy
state for that particle
is not the one in which it
collapses, but the one in which
it sort of forms an
appropriate interference
pattern around the nucleus,
but not collapse on it.
So if you want, it's truly
quantum mechanics at its heart.
And now, you see, if you
really want to sort of recover
some of the subtleties
that are somehow
invisible in this charge,
there's the picture.
If you want sort
of to recover what
are the tiny differences between
them sort of electronic levels,
well, what you
could do-- this is
sort of typical in a
transactional simulation.
You could take a
charge the difference
between a system in
which you have a methane
molecule attached
to the platinum,
or you don't have
a methane molecule.
And there, in this
difference, you
start sort of seeing patterns
of chemical bonding emerging.
And so you see sort
of places where
the charge density of your
system increases or decreases.
And you can start
seeing here actually
the d orbitals of the
platinum and the formation of
and the breaking of
the chemical bonds.
So there is this general
picture of atoms and spheres,
but then all what we care
are those subtle effects
that determine bonding.
And this is actually to put
some energy numbers on it.
Sort of this is
what relevant was.
We live at around 300
Kelvin, sort of give or take
1 order of magnitude.
And the kinetic
energy of an atom
in a sort of ideal
perfect gas is basically
0.04 electron volts.
So this is sort of
the average energy
that is available
because of temperature.
And so you can
understand that it's
sort of that is somehow a
button limit for chemical bonds.
If the chemical bonds
are, say, in our system,
we're going to be
comparable or smaller
than 0.04 electrons volts.
We would actually evaporate
right away and disappear.
So if we actually look at the
binding energy of the hydrogen
bond in a dimer between
two water molecule,
it's sort of roughly one
order of magnitude larger.
So really water at
room temperature
is sort of bound together.
It's a liquid at
0.29 electrons volts.
And now, you start understanding
the standard model of matter.
If you think at what is the
binding energy of an electron
just to a proton--
this is really the
hydrogen atom--
that binding energy is almost
2 orders of magnitude larger,
13 electron volts.
And so you can think
that, if we start
going from hydrogen to
the sort of other atoms
in the periodic table, the 1s
electron in the other atoms
are going to be even
more tightly bound.
And so they will
never be affected
by sort of the average energy
present at current temperature.
And actually, this number
scales as the square
of the atomic number.
So those core
electrons, in particular
those one core electrons, are
going to be terribly bound.
The only chemistry that we do
is with the highest electrons
whose binding energy is sort
of comparable, basically,
to this number.
OK, I think we are
particularly lucky in having
sort of a number of
books that are actually
excellent references for
electronic structure research
nowadays.
And I sort of mentioned here
three of the ones I like more.
They are all very recent.
There is the book from Richard
Martin at Urbana-Champaign
that I would really
say it's, by now,
the Bible of electronic
structure methods.
It's a very complete
and very detailed book.
So this is what
you would probably
want to have if you were
actually to do research
in electronic structure,
especially seen
from the point of view of
solid-state or condensed matter
and solids.
Another very beautiful
book that is, I think,
the closest in
spirit to this class
is the book by Mike
Finnis at the University
of Belfast, Interatomic
Forces in Condensed Matter.
It covers both quantum
mechanical approaches,
and it also shows how potential
approaches, as those described
by Professor Ceder in
the previous lectures,
actually emerge
very naturally from
quantum mechanical methods.
And we'll see a
little bit of this.
And the third book is by Tim
Kaxiras at Harvard University.
And again, it's an
electronic structure book
with a sort of very broad
perspective on solids
and condensed matter systems.
So any of this is actually
a very good reference.
And so what I want to do
after this introduction
in the next 15
minutes is give you
a refresher of quantum mechanics
in case you have never seen it.
And we can also discuss
actually some reading in case
you're interested.
And so this is how I do it.
If you go to London,
Piccadilly Circus, well, there
is the Reduced
Shakespeare Company.
They do in 90 minutes
all Shakespeare tragedies
and all Shakespeare comedies.
And so here the plan is to do
in 15 minutes all of quantum
mechanics sort of to give you
the flavor of what goes on.
And you see, reducing
expectation for over 20 years.
I actually really like them.
OK.
So this really goes
to answer the question
that we had before.
And that's sort
of, historically,
sort of between the 1900s and
sort of the mid-'20s, there was
a sort of emerging experimental
consensus on a number
of phenomenon.
The first one was sort of
studying the properties
of light in particular.
Light, ultimately, is
an electromagnetic wave.
And people discovered
the photoelectric effect.
That's actually Albert
Einstein paper 100 years ago.
This year is that the 100th
anniversary of the annus
mirabilis of Albert Einstein,
in which he was basically
giving an explanation of
the photoelectric effect.
There are illuminating material,
something like selenium.
And basically, your
electromagnetic radiation
excite discretely electrons
out of the material.
And that can sort
of be rationalized
in terms of quanta of energy,
discrete amounts of energy,
what we call photons
being exchanged.
So something that people
used to think as continuum,
as electromagnetic wave that can
have, say, any, in principle,
wavelength is actually
sort of made up
of massless particles
that have a sort
of discrete amount of energy.
So that was one thing.
The other thing that
sort of was fairly exotic
that Planck explained
and sort of, you know,
that's the birth
of quantum theory,
was actually looking
at the emission
of an incandescent body.
That's what is called
black body radiation.
And the spectrum
could be explained
in terms of excitation of a
gas-like of hot particles.
But again, spectrum is an
electromagnetic radiation.
And so there was this
sort of general idea
of electromagnetic waves have
particle-like properties.
What was really
sort of interesting
was sort of the discovery that
particles, like electrons,
can have wave-like properties.
And that actually
sort of determined,
ultimately, sort of the
development of wave mechanics
or quantum mechanics
and, in particular,
the Davisson-Germer
discovery that electron beams
can be refracted.
So electrons, when
you shoot electrons,
they are not behaving
as classical particle.
And they either sort of hit
something and bounce back,
or they go through.
But they actually diffract
and so behave as waves.
And sort of these
were sort of if you
want one of the key issues.
And how do we summarize this?
Well, this is actually sort
of one of fundamental ideas,
so one of the ideas that
I want you to remember
from quantum mechanics.
This is what is called
de Broglie relation.
It's from 1923.
It's what I call
actually the shortest PhD
thesis in the world.
There are only three
letters in that.
But sort of what it's
telling us is this.
There is a fundamental constant.
It's like gravitation.
In gravitation, you have a
fundamental constant that
is the attraction between mass.
Well, there is another
fundamental constant
that we call the
Planck constant.
And here is sort of
what its value is
in the international system.
And this is a relation that
all particles, all objects,
satisfy.
And it says that, if a particle
has a certain momentum, that is
has a certain mass
time velocity--
OK, so if a particle
has a certain momentum,
it will also display
wave-like properties.
And the wavelength typical
of those wave-like properties
is given by lambda.
So basically, you
have an electron.
You can sort of
plug in what would
be an average momentum
for that electron,
and you find out what
is the wavelength.
What it turns out is
that, if you plug here
the average momentum of a
valence electron, what you find
out is that the
wavelength that it has
is sort of comparable with
the interatomic distances.
So electrons behave
significantly
as waves at the length scale
that are relevant for you.
Because if you have two atoms
that are two angstrom far apart
and the electron is a
wavelength of 2 angstrom,
well, then we really
need to take into account
the wave-like
properties of electrons.
And you see, this is
why actually nuclei
we can get by just with
classical mechanics
because the mass of a
proton is 2,000 times
the mass of an electron.
So the mass of a nucleus is
at least 2,000 times larger
than the mass of an electron.
And you actually have sort of
tens of protons and neutrons.
So the typical
momentum is going to be
thousands, tens of
thousands, larger
than the momentum
of the electron.
And so the typical wavelength
is going to be at least a 3
or 4 orders of
magnitude smaller.
And so, now, the wavelength
of a nucleus start
to be 10 to the minus 14,
10 to the minus 15 meters,
is not relevant anymore for the
distance between the nuclei.
So for all practical purposes,
the wavelength of nuclei
is so small that
we can treat nuclei
as a point-like particles.
But the wave of electrons is
comparable to the distance,
and so we need to describe
electrons as waves.
And this relation is actually
very simple to sort of look
at in practical terms.
Instead of using the
international system of meters
and seconds and
so on, we actually
use a different system
of unit of measure.
That is what we
call atomic units.
Of course, no one forces
us to use the meter
as a unit of measure.
That was actually a byproduct
of the French Revolution.
So sort of a lot of people in
the general arena of chemistry
and solid state use different
sets of units of measure.
One of the most
difficult is atomic units
where the unit of length is
actually the typical radius
of 1 hydrogen atom.
So the sort of standard
measure gives us
0.53 angstrom or what is
called 1 Bohr for the radius
of an hydrogen atom.
And so this will
be an atomic unit.
So 1 angstrom is
roughly 2 atomic units.
In this scheme,
atomic unit system,
the Planck constant is
actually going to be 2 pi.
6.28, that's what
it turns out to be
when we sort of choose
appropriately all
the atomic units of measure.
And again, the atomic
unit of momentum, one
is going to be the
mass of an electron
times the velocity of
a 1s electron, again,
in a hydrogen atom.
So you see the electron
in the hydrogen atom
basically satisfy
perfectly Planck relation.
Because in atomic units, it's
momentum p is equal to 1.
And h, the Planck
constant, is equal to 2 pi.
So its wavelength is
going to be equal to 2 pi.
And if you think at the atom
as having a radius of 1,
you understand that
the wavelength of 2 pi
is the right
wavelength to basically
have along the diameter
1 single oscillation.
And so we sort of start
thinking at this ground
state of the
electron that doesn't
fall on the nucleus as
the fundamental harmonics
for this wave in the
presence of a potential.
OK.
There are cases in which the
quantum mechanical nature
of the nuclei actually
becomes relevant.
There is much less
modeling activity on that
because it's just fairly
computationally expensive.
One of the cases in
which it's important
is when you have a
very light nuclei.
So if you have a system
that has a lot of hydrogen,
well, it actually
might become relevant.
And the fact that your proton
has its own wavelength,
has its own delocalization,
could actually
become important.
And it's never going
to change dramatically
the physics of the
chemistry of your system,
but it's going to
introduce relevant effects.
And you know, this
is actually coming
from a Nature paper from 1999, a
very, very expensive simulation
in which both the electronics
degrees of freedom
were studied.
And also, the quantum
delocalization effects
on the proton were
studied, basically,
for what is called a
hydrated proton in water.
So if you have water and
you add a proton, well,
the first thing that will
form is a hydronium ion, H3O+.
And for 20, 30 years,
people had actually
discussed what was the general
coordination of this proton.
There was sort of a hypothesis
in which people were discussing
about an Eigen
compound, from Eigen,
the person that
first suggested it,
a proton bound to two water
molecules basically creating
an H5O 2+ system.
And then there was the Zundel
hypothesis in which this
hydronium ion, H3O+, was
surrounded by three water
molecules.
And you know-- nothing
better than doing an accurate
simulation to find it out.
And being finally a quantum
mechanical simulation,
the result was
that it's actually
the proton is in what is
called a functional state.
Sort of it stays half of the
time in an Eigen state, that
is a state predicted
by Eigen, and half
of the time in a Zundel state.
And you see this is
actually interesting,
sort of comparing the
quantum mechanical prediction
and the classical prediction.
That is for a classical proton
in a quantum mechanical field
of electrons.
And you see the sort
of average position
in the proton
between two molecules
are sort of more
delocalized, more spread out,
than in the classical case.
So that is, I think,
the structure of water
is interesting.
There are sort of
other cases in which
you have a very shallow energy
barrier between two states
in which the quantum
delocalization and the quantum
tunneling could be important.
And something like that happened
actually in strontium titanite.
That is a perovskite very
similar to the lead titanite
that we have seen
in the first slide.
And we remember there were
two phases, a cubic phase
and a distorted
ferroelectric phase.
Well, it turns out that in the
case of strontium titanite,
the energy barrier
between those two phases
is so shallow that
all the ions actually
tunnel back and forth between
all the possible structure.
And so a system that
would be ferroelectric
in a classical simulation of
the ions, when we actually
introduce a quantum mechanical
effect for the nucleus as well,
it turns out to be the
state that keeps tunneling
between all the possibilities.
And so it doesn't
display ferroelectricity.
The last case that is
probably the most relevant--
and we'll see that
in more detail,
so I haven't presented here--
in which we really need
to take into account
the quantum mechanical
nature of the ions
has to do with
structural excitation.
When you put temperature, say,
in something like a solid,
you don't excite vibrational
states in a continuum way.
But you actually excite
discrete vibrational states
of your system.
And this is sort of
fundamental to understand
many thermodynamical properties
of solid, of molecules,
something like the
specific heat of a solid.
But we'll see examples
of that later on.
And those are cases
in which we actually
know very well on how to deal
with this specific problem
of the quantization of
the vibrational excitation
of your system.
OK.
So with all of this, the
first thing to remember
is that electrons
actually behave as waves.
So in reality, what
is quantum mechanics?
It's nothing else
than the mechanics
of electrons as waves.
So we don't consider
it a mechanics
of classical particle,
but it's the mechanics
of wave-like objects.
And there are going to be very
specific laws if you want them.
There's going to be the
Schrodinger equation that
is the Newton equivalent
of the equation of motion.
But there are also
going to be very
specific computational
constraints
on how we describe a wave.
OK.
What you are very
familiar is sort
of the mechanics of a particle.
So in the mechanics
of a particle,
you have Newton
equation of motion.
You have mass times acceleration
is equal to the force.
That's an ordinary second-order
differential equation.
That basically
means that what you
are going to obtain
by integrating
this equation of
motion is actually
the trajectory as
a function of time
and the first derivative
that is the velocity.
And because its second-order
differential equation,
what you really need
to define that is, say,
something like the
initial condition.
You need to define
where your particle is
at a certain instant and
what is its velocity.
And once you know that
and you know, say,
what is the force, something
like the gravitational force
in this case, well, you are able
to integrate your trajectory.
OK.
So this is sort of integration
of the equation of motion.
But what is really important
is that your dynamical system
that is your particle moving
around is perfectly described.
So we know everything
about that particle.
If I have every instant in
time, I give you two vectors,
basically.
I give the position,
and I give the velocity.
And in a sort of three
dimension, that's six numbers.
OK.
So it's very easy to remember.
And it's very easy to
store in a computer.
And this is my last
slide for today.
The amazing
computational complexity
that we have when we actually
need to describe a wave
is that to describe a
wave that is basically
a delocalized excitation a
wave is an amplitude everywhere
in space.
So even to describe a single
electron, what we need to say
is that at every instant what
is the amplitude of that wave
everywhere in space.
And so you see we have gone
from a classical particle that
was basically six
numbers at every instant
to a quantum mechanical
particle that at every instant,
in principle, requires a field
that covers all the space.
So we need to specify the
amplitude everywhere in space.
And this becomes worse
and worse as the number
of particle increases.
Suppose that we
had two electrons.
Well, what we need
to give is now
an amplitude at a
certain instant of time
that would be a function of one
vector r and another vector r2.
So if, by any chance,
you were satisfied
by sort of describing this
in a discretized form--
you see sort of discretizing
space and giving the amplitude
at every point in space.
And say to describe
an electron, you
could be happy by just
giving, say, a million points.
Well, if you want to
describe two electrons,
you have to give 1 million
times 1 million points.
And three electrons--
1 million to the cube
and so on and so forth.
So just the computational
complexity of this object
explodes.
That is ultimately
why it is so difficult
to solve the equivalent of the
Newton's equation of motion
for a quantum particle that
is the Schrodinger equation.
And so with this, I'll conclude
that, if you need any reading
on sort of fundamental
quantum mechanics,
I can give you a suggestion.
In general, sort of
physical chemistry textbooks
do a very good job.
There is a quantum
mechanical book
that is called the Bransden
and Joachain Quantum
Mechanics that is very good.
But what you need
for this class you'll
sort of see in the
next few slides
and in the beginning
of next lecture.
And then really we'll
sort of start describing
electronic structure methods.
That is, how do we deal
with this complexity?
And how do we apply it
to practical system?
And so with this
appointment on Thursday--
same time, but in room 1115.
And then we meet again for
class here next Tuesday.